cada vez más desesperante la situación
en mariupol donde por segundo día
consecutivo ha fracasado el cese al
fuego y esto es lo que está impidiendo
que la población civil pueda ser
evacuada de la ciudad es lo que han
informado las autoridades ucranianas sin
embargo ambos bandos se están acusando
de estar violando justamente el cesa
fuego y por tanto están imposibilitando
esta evacuación y al mismo tiempo el
gobierno de kybse ha dicho en las
últimas horas que se prepara para un
ataque ruso en la ciudad de odessa en el
sur también una noticia que llega
después de que se conociese también que
en quiebra siguen habiendo ataques a
estructuras estratégicas como una
central eléctrica a 100 kilómetros al
sur de la capital ucraniana y continúa
también el hecho de personas que siguen
luchando hacia el oeste y hacia la
frontera con la unión europea un éxodo
que estamos viviendo en persona al mismo
tiempo de que vemos que los ucranianos
han empezado a construir también en el
este del país
trincheras trincheras que están siendo
construidas en campos agrícolas como en
guerras de otros tiempos